hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about the
epic madness of the latest events in the
black clover story
we are finally learning more about
asta's demon slash devil
and in fact for the first time the
anti-magic devil
is emerging out into the open what's
more
it looks like osta is about to fight his
own devil
in a bid to get stronger and learn to
harness his true power
things are getting absolutely heated so
let's do this
before we start this is actually the
first video that i am recording
after hitting 1 million subscribers here
on the channel
honestly huge thank you to each and
every one of you who took the time to
subscribe and hit
that notification bell one million
subscribers
is a huge accomplishment but it's an
accomplishment that depends
completely on you guys one million is
not just a number
that is a million individual people
taking the time to subscribe
and support us both me and my brother
gozan are extremely blessed
and grateful for all of you if you're
subscribed please drop me a comment
saying that you are and if you remember
when you subscribed let me know
down below also a big thank you to all
of our editors who help us put these
videos out
including my boy dakota broski who is
editing this video
this man is a hard worker a huge black
clover fan
and he has his own anime youtube channel
so definitely show him some love
link to his channel is in the
description and of course as usual this
video will contain black clover manga
spoilers etc etc
let's get into it the latest installment
of the story starts off with an amazing
cover that features knocked and his 4
animalistic shadow demons the text on
the cover page reads
be one with the darkness of the night
and hide
inside the shadows i just thought that
this was a really interesting cover so i
wanted to point it out
knocked is such an incredible intriguing
character
and his shadow magic is so cool and so
mysterious
and i'm looking forward to learning more
about him in the previous chapter we
spent our time with the
elves in elysia and i thought that the
action in this chapter would probably
keep us
in that same location but i was wrong
because this chapter gave us something
totally different and it was absolutely
freaking
epic first we saw julius getting in
touch with gaia from the heart kingdom
the clover kingdom and heart kingdom
leaders are planning a joint strategy to
take on
the dark triad and gaia confirms that
together with the elves the heart
kingdom warriors are preparing to strike
so if anyone was still wondering whether
the elves will get involved
it seems like they definitely will
during this conversation it is clear
that both
gaia and charlotte are furious that the
dark triad
managed to kidnap loro pachika and yami
and of course they are determined to do
whatever it takes to save their loved
ones
we know that charlotte's love for yami
is romantic
in nature but i'm not sure if there is a
romantic element to gaia's relationship
with loro pachika
it could be that he is just upset
because he is loyal to his queen
or there could be something more
personal going on but we'll have to wait
and see
at any rate you guys know that i'm not
big on shipping and all that type of
stuff
except when it comes to shipping myself
with vanessa and potentially
mero leona next up the chapter takes us
to the black bull's headquarters where
nacht has finally arrived knocked is
busy explaining to the other black bulls
that a surprise attack on the spade
kingdom will take place in three days
and this attack will include the clover
kingdom's most
elite fighters but funeral vanessa and
gray are straight up shocked to see
knocked
in the first place it seems that despite
being members of the black bulls for
much longer than asta
even they had never actually met knocked
before
when funeral asks why the vice captain
of the black bulls has never been to
headquarters
in all of this time knocked responds by
saying that he hates
the black bulls finral and the others
are like wait
what and knocked explains that he became
the vice captain in the first place so
that he would have the freedom to do his
own thing without needing to have
anything to do
with the other black bulls nacht says
that he hates people who don't do
things properly and the black bulls are
a bunch of misfits and outcasts who
often end up being more trouble than
they're worth
knocked then goes on to take personal
shots and multiple members of the black
bulls
and i can forgive him for all of the
others but i was deeply offended when he
called
my girl vanessa a vulgar drunkard witch
okay screw you knocked vanessa is a
beautiful queen
and yes when it comes to vanessa i'm a
proud
tier 3 simp i mean sub okay and even as
knocked insults the black bulls and
calls them useless bastards
it is clear that he actually knows a lot
about each and every one of them
if not really didn't care about the
black bulls
then why did he go through all of that
trouble to learn about
each individual member despite never
even having met
them keeping that in mind and keeping in
mind
noct's tendency to say that he hates
stuff when it is clear that he doesn't
i am going to go out on a limb and say
that noct actually
likes the black bulls he just seems to
be an eccentric
guy who likes to work alone most of the
time after all
why would he serve as the vice captain
of the black bulls for all of these
years if he really hated
the entire squad as knocked leaves by
using shadow magic to literally sink
into the ground he tells the black bulls
to try and get stronger
in the next two days this heavily
implies that even regular
black bulls members will be included in
the surprise attack
in some way so this means that it won't
be just the magic knight captains and
vice captains who are going to be taking
part
in this fight along with asta it seems
that the other black bulls are also
expected to take part
which is why noct advises them to get
stronger
this is very interesting since i was
kind of assuming that the elite unit of
fighters who will infiltrate the spate
kingdom is going to be pretty small
i was thinking like 10 to 15 of the
clover kingdom's most
elite mages but if the regular squad
members of the black bulls are also
going to be involved
and if we count everyone in the heart
kingdom who will be involved as well
then we can assume that this surprise
attack will be a pretty big one
maybe some of the weaker mages will
serve as some sort of diversion that
will allow the stronger mages to get to
yami and william more
quickly but we'll have to wait and see
the final part of the chapter
features knocked taking osta into a
creepy abandoned mansion
in the middle of nowhere this mansion
which is empty and falling apart
once belonged to a certain noble but
knocked
doesn't mention who that noble was i
think that the identity of this snowball
might become relevant
in future chapters was this perhaps
knocked old family home one of the boys
in an old photograph
inside the house does look like he could
be a young knocked
but it's impossible to tell for sure
during his conversation with asta
noct takes a moment to talk about his
awesome shadow magic
and i'm all for it because i really want
to know more about this supremely cool
magic attribute noct says that his
shadow magic
works kind of like spatial magic in the
sense that it allows him and anyone or
anything that he touches to travel from
one
shadow to another i wonder if that means
that he can literally travel from his
own shadow to
any shadow in the world or if there are
some restrictions
for example can he travel from where he
is now to literally
any shadow in the spade kingdom capital
or
can he only travel within a certain
range can he only travel to shadows
whose specific locations he already
knows
can he only travel to places that he's
like physically touched or something
and so on i'm extremely excited to learn
more about shadow magic
this magic attribute really is a game
changer and it is already clear to
everyone that shadow magic will be
absolutely crucial for the spade kingdom
infiltration plan
after knocked takes osta into what looks
like an old study
he uses his magic to cover the entire
room in
shadows he calls this spell temptation
of black
garden and the next thing we know a
bunch of shadow arms
grab osta and pull him down into some
sort of shadow realm
noct explains that they will spend the
next two days inside
this shadow realm by the way shadow
realm is just what i'm calling in that's
not in the chapter
and during that time knocked will teach
osta
everything he knows about the power of a
devil asta
is excited about this quick training arc
and noct tells asta that the reason why
he hasn't been able to get stronger
is because he is not controlling the
power of his devil
up to this point osta has just been
using the power that has been leaking
out of the anti-magic devil but it seems
that noct is about to change the game
completely by
having us to make a formal contract with
his devil
this will allow asta to bring out the
full potential of his devil's power
just like noct and the dark triad are
able to do
according to noct asta needs to
establish a connection between himself
and the devil normally this is done
through artifacts
and knocked shows that he has a necklace
with four different
items hanging from it presumably each of
the four items is related to one of his
animalistic shadow demons these
artifacts are used to establish a
connection with the devil
and then the devil can be summoned into
this world for a limited amount of time
however asta is different
he doesn't have any sort of artifact
that connects him to his devil
osta's very existence is his connection
with the devil after all both osta's
grimoire
and his new demonic arm are directly
connected to the anti-magic devil
in the very next moment knocked utters
the word
goma and suddenly asta's body is
engulfed by black
flames i'm guessing that the word goma
here is just a reference to the japanese
word goma
which means demon but i'm not sure if
this word was just used to summon the
anti-magic devil
or if this word itself is more
significant
for example we still don't know the
anti-magic devil's real name
but we'll have to wait and see what the
various different translations have to
say
at any rate the anti-magic devil appears
before asta
at the same time as austa's demonic arm
dissolves
into nothing and then the devil laughs
and says that asta will be the one
to let him out in the panel that
accompanies these words
we see asta's devil seemingly taking
over his entire body
and nakht then tells asta that he must
fight against his devil and he must win
that is how this mind-blowing chapter
ends
and things are now happening very
quickly and changing very rapidly
in the black clover story apparently
asta must somehow
fight his own devil in order to unlock
the devil's true
power this might seem kind of confusing
but this is what i assume
knocked meant when he said this i think
that asta must learn to summon the
anti-magic devil
into this world and to let him manifest
while at the same time not allowing the
devil to take
over his body i assume that this is what
nacht is trying to teach
asta asta must learn to control his
devil so that
even when he does manifest in the
physical world for a limited time
the devil won't completely take over
asta's body and
osta's consciousness but the big
question is
how will this training process actually
work
how is osta supposed to fight the devil
is it a battle of wits
is it a battle of wills is it a physical
contest we know it's not a magic contest
since asta has no magic
but i'm definitely intrigued to see what
will happen next
and in fact a lot of what happens next
will depend on the anti-magic devil
himself
and on his true intentions we know very
little
about this creature we don't even know
his name so we can only guess what his
true intentions
are is the anti-magic devil interested
in taking over asta
and making aston a prisoner in his own
body
or is the devil interested in working
together with asta
in order to defeat lucifer and dante is
he may be interested in seducing mario
leona we just don't know
but this question of what the anti-magic
devil really wants
will be crucial going forward my own
personal guess
is that the anti-magic devil is going to
challenge osta
to a battle of wits strength and will
but in the end i think that the devil
does want to work together with osta
we know how upset the anti-magic devil
was back when he and osta
lost to dante and lucifer so i believe
that asta's devil
does want osta to get stronger so that
they can have a rematch
i'm not sure why exactly the anti-magic
devil was so upset about losing to dante
but i'm sure that we will find out
soon please let me know what you guys
think are you excited about asta's devil
finally coming out and manifesting
into this world and what do you think
his true intentions
are is asta about to lose control of his
own body
or is he about to partner up with the
devil and unlock new levels of power
that he could only have dreamed of
before
and if he does do this how much stronger
is the nuasta
going to be leave your thoughts down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black clover content here on
the channel please drop a like to let me
know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to the channel or you just
haven't subscribed yet please consider
subscribing
and hitting that notification bell to
turn on all notifications
we are now at over 1 million subscribers
which is completely insane
thank you guys so much i want to give a
big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible a special thank you to alpha
sigma
and liam thompson disciples of lord
twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including
ingrada the world acquired respect pate
heffa
jonathan king rathune de ora emperor
otaku
thomas jones kin mano admirath and
chris torley finally thank you also to
our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
king zeldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci
alicia octor hinokamian water bonnie
parks
jason wilson florian joy and garcia
steelers mcshamus jessica kayla fond
deadly saint
stern hawkins and highschool dxd73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
becoming a patron
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space
[Music]
cowboys
[Music]
you